in this video you learn about the beam
search algorithm in the last video you
remember how for machine translation
given an input French sentence you don't
want to output a random English
translation you want output the best the
most likely English translation the same
is also true for speech recognition
where given an input audio clip you
don't want to output a random text
transcript of that audio you an output
the best maybe the most likely text
transcript beam search is the most
widely used algorithm to do this and in
this video you see how to get beam
search to work for yourself let's
describe beam search using our running
example of the French sentence Jane's is
equally free concept on hopefully being
translated into Jane visits Africa in
September the first thing beam search
has to do is try to pick the first word
of the English translation that's going
to output so here I've listed I'll say
ten thousand words in the vocabulary and
to simplify the problem a bit I'm going
to ignore capitalization so I'm just
listing all the words in lowercase so in
the first step of beam search or use
this network fragment with the encoder
shown in green and the decode is shown
in purple to try to evaluate what is the
probability of that first word so what's
the probability of the first output Y
given the input sentence x given the
French input so we're as greedy search
will pick only the one most likely words
and move on beam search instead can
consider multiple alternatives so the
beam search algorithm has a parameter
called B which is called the beam width
and for this example I'm gonna set the
beam width to be equal to three and what
this means this beam search because
they're not just one possibility but
consider three at a time so in
particular let's say evaluating this
probability over different choices the
first word it finds that the choices in
Jane and September are the most likely
three possibilities for the first words
in the English output then beam search
will store away in computer memory that
it wants to try out all three of these
words and if the beam with parameter was
said differently if the beam width
parameter was say 10
then we keep track of not just three but
of the ten most likely possible choices
for the first word so to be clear in
order to perform this first step of beam
search what you need to do is run the
input French sentence through this
encoder network and then this first step
of the decoder network if this is a soft
max output over all 10,000 possibilities
then you would take those 10,000
possible outputs and keep in memory
which were the top of the week let's go
on to the second step of beam search
having picked in Jane and September as
the three most likely choice of the
first word what beam search will do now
is for each of these three choices
consider what should be the second word
so after in maybe the second word is a
or maybe it's Erin I'm just listing
words from the faux caviar from the
dictionary or somewhere down to this
will be September somewhere down the
list is visit and all the way to Z maybe
the last word is Zulu so to evaluate the
probability is second word it will use
this neural network fragments where
there's the encoder and green and for
the decoder portion when trying to
decide what comes off the in remember
the decoder first outputs why that's one
so we're going to set to this y hat one
to the word in and feed this back in so
this is the words in because it decided
for now that because we're trying to
figure out it the first word was in what
is the second word and then this will
output yes Y hat too and so by
hardwiring y hat one here really the
input here to be the first word in this
network fragment can be used to evaluate
what is the probability of the second
word given the input French sentence and
that the first word of the translation
has been the word it now notice that
what we ultimately care about in this
second step of being search is to find
the pair of the first and second words
that is most likely so not just a sec
where this most likely but the pair of
the first and second rows it most likely
and by the rules of conditional
probability this can be expressed as P
of the first word times P of probability
of the second word right which you're
getting from this new network fragment
and so if for each of the three words
you've chosen in Jane and September
you've saved away this probability then
you can multiply them by this second
probability to get the probability of
the first and second words so now you've
seen how if the first word was in how
you can evaluate the probability of the
second word now if the first word was
Jane you'd do the same thing the
sentence could be Jane a Jane Erin and
so on down to Jane is Jane visits and so
on and you will use this neural network
fragment and let me draw this in as well
we're here you would Hotwire Y had one
to eat Jane and so with the first word
y1 hat
hardwired as Jane then this new network
fragments can tell you was it probably
if the second words give me input X and
given that the first word was Jane and
then same as above you can multiply with
P of y1 to get the probability of y 1
and y 2 for each of these 10,000
different possible choices for the
second word and then finally you do the
same thing for September all the words
from a down to Zulu and use this network
fragment
I just told us in as well so see if the
first word was September
what weather the most likely options for
the second word so for this second step
of beam search because we're continuing
to use a beam width of three and because
there are 10,000 words in the vocabulary
you'd end up considering three times ten
thousand or thirty thousand
possibilities because there are ten
thousand here
ten thousand year ten thousand years
isn't being worth been since the beam
width times the number of words in the
vocabulary and what you do is you
evaluate all of these thirty thousand
options according to the probability of
the first and second word and then pick
the top three so we're gonna cut down
these thirty thousand possibilities down
to three year getting down to the beam
width parameter again and so let's say
that these thirty thousand choices the
most likely were in September and say
Jane is and Jane visits sorry this bit
messy but those are the most likely
three out of the thirty thousand choices
then that's what beam search would
memorize away and take on to the next
step of beam search so notice one thing
if beam search decides that the three
most likely choices for the first and
second words are in September or Jane is
or Jane visits then what that means is
that it is now rejecting September as a
candidate for the first word of the
output English translation so we're now
down to two possibilities for the first
word but we still have a beam worth of
three keeping track of three choices for
pairs of y1 y2 before going on to the
third step of beam search just wanna
notice that because the beam width is
equal to three at every step you
instantiate three copies of the network
to evaluate these partial sentence
fragments in the output and it's because
the beam width is equal to three that
you have three copies of the network
with different choices
for the first word but these three
copies of the network can be very
efficiently used to evaluate all 30,000
options for the second word so just
don't instantiate 30,000 copies in the
network you need only three copies of
the network to very quickly evaluate all
10,000 possible outputs that that
softmax outputs a 4y 2 let's just
quickly illustrate one more step of beam
search so said that the most likely
choices for first two words were in
September genius and Jane visits and for
each of these pairs of words we should
have saved the way in computer memory
the probability of y 1 and y 2 given the
input next given the French sentence X
so similar to before we now want to
consider what is the third word so is it
in September a in September Aaron all
the way down to is in September
Zulu and to evaluate possible choices
for the third word you use this network
fragment where you hardwire the first
word here to be in the second word to be
September and so this network fragment
allows you to evaluate what's the
probability of the third word given the
input French sentence X and given that
the first two words are in September in
the English output and then you do the
same thing for the second fragment so
like so and same thing for Jane visits
and so being searchable then once again
pick the top three possibilities maybe
things in September Jane is a likely
outcome or Jane is visiting as likely or
maybe Jane versus Africa is likely for
the first three words and then it keeps
going and then you go on to the fourth
step of beam search that had one more
word and on it girls and the outcome of
this process hopefully will be that
adding one word at a time that beam
search will decide that
Jane versus African September will be
terminated by the end of
and symbol using that in your system
which is quite common that will find
that this is a likely output English
sentence and you see more details of
this for yourself in this week's spring
exercise as well where you get to play
with beam search yourself so with a beam
worth of three beam search considers
three possibilities at a time notice
that um if the beam wave was said to be
equal to one so considers only one then
this essentially becomes the greedy
search algorithm which we had discussed
in the last video but by considering
multiple possibilities say three or ten
or some of the number at the same time
beam search will usually find a much
better output sentenced and greedy
search you've now seen how beam search
works but it turns out there's some
additional tips and tricks and
refinements that helps you to make beam
search work even better let's go onto
the next video to take a look